there's been an awakening
hey youtubers is Charlie so very
familiar lightsaber appearing in new
Star Wars footage so this is gonna be a
breakdown along with some new things
that we learned from d23 so big stuff
first some of the old footage spliced in
with John boyega holding the lightsaber
that he was holding in that one sheet
that they were giving away at d23 they
were giving away a poster to everyone
that went to the panel and it looked
like he was holding Anakin Skywalker's
lightsaber if you remember back in one
of the older trailers it looked like
someone was passing Anakin's lightsaber
to Leia that doesn't necessarily mean
that John boyega
is related to Anakin Skywalker in any
way it just means that he's going to be
one of the New Jedi just confirms that
and I know some of you guys were bummed
because Daisy Ridley wasn't holding a
lightsaber on that one sheet but that
doesn't mean that she's not force
sensitive it just means that they're
hyping up John boyega right now Daisy
Ridley is gonna be a badass too we just
we just don't know what kind of badass
yet as for the other Jedi in here or
Dark Jedi however you want to think
about him kylo Ren we learned some stuff
about him he is part of an order called
the Knights of Ren that's where his name
comes from JJ Abrams said that that is
not the name that he was born with it's
kind of like Anakin Skywalker taking the
name Darth Vader he's taking a lot of
his cues from Darth Vader he's taking
inspiration especially in the mask that
he built for himself but he is working
for Supreme Leader Snoke
that's who Andy Serkis is characters
playing and that's who's doing the
voice-over in this little teaser all we
know about him is that he has a super
deep connection to the force that has
nothing to do with the Sith now and
everybody's like holding their hands up
saying does that mean that the
retconning the Sith no they're not
retconning Sith it just means that
they're part of a different order of
Jedi the way JJ Abrams explained the
first order like the remnants of the
Empire is that it what would happen if
all the Nazis after World War two went
to Argentina and started working
together again
would they be able to like it's
basically a bunch of people left in the
rubble of the empire that felt like
there's unfinished work they felt like
the Empire were the protagonists of the
original trilogy as silly as that sounds
it sounds like some of the stuff that
Adam driver was saying at Comic Con
where it's like yeah he's playing an
evil character but because they feel
like they're doing the right thing it
becomes institutionalized evil which is
sometimes way worse than just a
straight-up villain it's like they
perpetrate all these atrocities because
they think that they're doing the
right thing for the galaxy which is kind
of like the Empire from the original
trilogy if you ever read some of the
expanded novel so you actually you meet
a lot of the people that work in and
around the Empire and most of them
aren't super evil they're just people
working a job but I got to say I'm super
hype about John boyega using a
lightsaber you guys can let me know do
you think that that is actually Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber because it seems
like it is and we do know now that kylo
Ren actually did build his himself too
so you can chalk up the fact that it's
so unrefined looking to the fact that he
is not fully trained in the classic art
of building lightsabers so what's gonna
happen is is because they posted a
really short version of this they might
post an even longer version next week if
they do I'll totally do a video for it
be sure to subscribe to get that if they
don't I'll just do a regular Star Wars
bonus video if there's anything that you
guys want me to do it on just let me
know in the comments if you guys haven't
seen it yet you can click here for my
Star Wars d23 video I just talked a
little bit about the one sheet and do
like a breakdown of some of the stuff
that they talked about there and you can
click here for the last Star Wars
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high bye I'll see you
guys tonight
you